Hãy hà miệng từ thằng chiến năm 2018,
thông tin từ công an tình hà tính,
đơn vị vừa với hộp của cuộc cạnh rất hiện sự,
công an các tình.
Phá được giới liên tình chuyên sản xuất,
một bản thúc khí, tui giữa năm 2018, khổ xuống các lại một trong bà mình in viên á.
Chứ đó, qua công tám nắm tình hình,
phòng cạnh rất hiện sự, công an hà tính,
và hiện một số đối tự trên địa bản có hình vì tảng chứ,
sự dụng xuống hơi face bề.
Nhan đám ở giống sắp mình,
và hiện một đường dây sản xuất,
một bản bụng khi quân dụ trên khong dành mà,
hoa đồng có tổ chức,
nhưng quan đến nhiều đối tự trên cả nước,
trước khi mô và tính chất nghiên trọng của vụ an,
phòng cạnh rất hiện sự đã bao gáo cuộc hình sự,
một công an để giác lập chuyên an đấu tranh,
bó khớt,
sau một thời gian đều trà,
bà chuyên an rất định đối tự cần đầu lần của quang viếc,
sinh năm 2019,
chú tại xá lân thào, tính bắc ni.
Thế đó,
vào tháng 1 năm 2018,
vì đã đặc muối các lại ông Thép,
lo sò,
đặt làm bằng ổ tại các cơ sở cửh khi,
làm một đề ra câu,
khoan cải,
chia thạo các bộ phận của xuống,
nhé các nghiên cứu không thể chia thác,
bình nên khi,
ông ám,
bán từ các sản thương mại địa từ ở Trung Quốc,
đặt muối các bạn đã chiếc,
của các đối tự ở Việt Nam trên mạng xó hội đề bán cho người muối.
Ví cũng đặt muối các bạn mấy cửh khi,
mấy nền hơi,
mấy em thị lực,
mấy tịt,
khoan cắt,
đồng thời thời lại tân nhà vá tần ở sá kể sát,
khi cũng hải phòng,
đề làm địa điểm tật kết,
sản xuất,
lắp sát,
đồng hỏi các lại vụ khí,
đình kết.
Ví thê và hủ sẫn ngô văn chọc,
sinh nămu nghiên triển trăm triển miếng tư,
chú tại sả lưng thào,
tình bất nền,
để trong trực tiếp xét thạo,
ra con có mình kính vụ khí,
khoan nế,
đồng hỏi,
ra các đơn hàng,
khoan video hủ sẫn,
là chim khoảng 8 xần phẩm,
ra dịch mua bán trên các mạng xã hội,
ra lâu,
telegram,
vay bờ và dưới tụp.
Nhân trình sự phát hiện của lực lượng trực năng,
các đời tượng đồng hỏi,
vì chào vụ khí dồi quà xe khách,
khoa các đơn hàng tương vạy tự cho người mua,
đến thằng tư năm 2018,
Ví có kết,
đường sẵn phát đời tự ửa của sả lưng thào,
tình bất nền,
ổng,
mến thình đô,
sinh nămu nghiên triển trăm triển miếng tư,
1 văn vình,
sinh nămu nghiên triển trăm triển miếng 2,
mến đồng,
sinh nămu nghiên triển trăm triển miếng 1,
trình thân thái,
sinh nămu nghiên triển trăm triển miếng 2,
tạo lực kinh bán hàng triển mạng xa hội.
Hí có hình mua,
các đời tượng này lấy lưng kịt
đặt dùng phê xe phê tự ửa vý sau đó
chuyển tất đơn hàng qua dịch vụ dào hàng.
Sau khi người mua chả tiền,
khi các nghiên vình chuyển tiền và tệ khoản nâng hàng cả nhân của viết,
tương nghiệm 1 một tháng 1 năm 2018,
khi được khoản lý,
sự dụp vụ khí,
bất nội,
con khủ hỗ trợ có hiệu lực,
các đời tượng hoạt động công chiều,
chủ yếu chuyển sang gia công,
bán các lại lưng kịt,
chỉ bán một số lại số cho các đời tượng tình tượng.
Mô văn miệng vấn đề tình đô đắt lươi một cách nhà tại sát cầm dàng,
thình phố hệ phòng,
để cất số,
đong cói,
qua video hướng giấn các đơn hàng.
Ngài ra,
theo các khoản công an,
nhóm của viết và lựa giúp xưa hợi trong việc kinh trà hàng quá
vẫn chuyển của công phía sau hàng nhân định
và chuyển hơn bán y năm 2018 là lấy kịt xú đảm ổ.
Bán chắc các đời tượng trên tượng của với tổng số tiền rào dịch hàng chục đi đông.
Ngài mẹ hai thằng chiến năm 2018,
giữ sự chỉ đạo của cuộc kảnh rất hiện sự,
hơn 2 trong khán bộ,
chính sĩ của bộ công an,
phòng kảnh rất hiện sự,
công an hả tính,
và công an các tình có lưng quan.
Đồng là chỉ 2,8 mẹ bà tổ công tác,
mất người khám sét và sự tập cân cấp 8 mẹ bà đối tượng tại New Year Foo.
Hả tính,
mấy đối tượng,
mất ninh,
hả tính,
lấy châu,
tu dưới năm 2018,
khổ xuống các lại,
một trong 8 mẹ mẹ mẹ nguyên đại,
hàng nghìn kịt xú và mấy móc,
thì bị dùng cho việc sản xuất phu khí.
Qua đối trên bà đồng,
lực lượng chỉ bằng sau định đủ dây này đã hoạt động
từ năm 2018,
của trong mi chính và tu lợi bất chính hàng chục đi đông.
Đây là chính công đặc biệt xuất sắc được lãnh đạo
bộ công an người thứ khé ngợi,
ổng,
cuộc kánh rất hiện sự,
công an tính hả tính,
công an tính lấy châu,
cho thấy sự nỗ lực không gồm của lực lượng công an trong công tác đối trên phòng chống tuit phạc.
Đà bảo an ninh chực tự,
nhất là trong đường ra quân cơ định công trên át tuit phạc,
bảo đảm an ninh an tòa đại hụi đảng cơ cấp.